before I kick off an earnest obviously
this is about Alexa and conversational
apps and go but there is a quick warning
I want to give to people who everyone
nowadays who have something that listens
to them particularly true for people
listening at home later on on YouTube
and have an Alexa device nearby I'm
gonna say let's go over it was go over
real quick
that's your echo there's the mute button
but I'm gonna want to use that and or
just not listen to this talk because I'm
gonna say Alexa a lot so fair warning
okay so yeah good afternoon my name is
Mike Flynn this is an incomplete list of
things about me I'm the chief technology
officer at Studio 71 which is a meeting
network and talent agency based in Los
Angeles I used to be here from st. Louis
though and I was a architect for answers
and if those you were from st. Louis my
remember a little blog I used to do here
and I'm talking to you now so that's why
I do for work what this talk this has
nothing to do with this at all what this
talk about is where my hobby in the last
year I guess year and a half which is
talking to computers and getting the
Alexa to do the different things I
wanted to do I love talking to computers
I don't know why it might be because of
years of science fiction that used
computers as plot devices but for some
reasons in my brain and I love them and
so when the echo came out I got one
right away and used it way more than I
thought and then they released the SDK
and it was game over I was making all
kinds of little things and playing
around the platform one of the early
things I built was a very first
unofficial Jeopardy app on the on the
Alexa and I stress unofficial because I
don't want to get sued and those
eyebrows are serious they've since made
an official look mine's better but um
I've also been a bunch of helper
libraries which we're gonna cover it a
little bit and I recently made an app
called tunnel
or echo tunnel that allows you to you
talk to your Alexa device and you can
connect to one of your computers then
you can send a command so you could say
you know connect my iMac and then lock
and your computer will lock remotely
things like that so why have I spent a
healthy chunk of my 2016 on silly Alexa
apps and things well what is the big
deal with these apps so beyond just you
know making it say jokes and being weird
with it and making slides about Alex
Trebek which I'm gonna leave up as long
as possible is you know the idea look
you you talk in plain language right
you're not sending commands and CLI
interface you have to speak a certain
way the idea is you just talk and we've
come a long way years ago you know we
had IRC commands that you would kind of
talk did throw into conversation you'd
come in bots with them you'd kick people
out of the room but they're hardly
conversational they're effectively
command-line right and those are still
around today and that's great
slack uses basically the exact same
paradigm but this year we've seen an
explosion of truly conversational apps
where you're just talking regular
language and you know Siri Google
assistant as it's now called same with
typing Facebook Messenger and I'm
obviously Amazon aleko and Alexa each of
these platforms allow you to talk in
regular language and can do commands
without having to do it particularly
that's talking and they all have varying
degrees of custom application support
but but we're gonna kind of focus this
on Alexa because it's the one that's
been at the longest so why why was 2016
the year where these apps exploded well
I've got a few theories for that first
is cost right I mean like everything in
computing things are getting cheaper all
the time and platforms like wit AI which
Facebook bought of a year or so ago
Google Cloud and was on Web Services
have shown that you can roll your own
ways of analyzing natural language
cheaply and responsive enough that you
can have a conversation to competition
you know it's it's some degree
if Amazon Facebook Apple and Google
decide they're gonna work on something
that didn't really matter if we like it
or not but but we do like it it's good
right these these big people are
competing and they're fighting over
things and we've seen it accelerate over
the last year because of it and then you
know novelty any new interface is going
to be novel right you've got people
making Siri tell jokes or you can have
Alexis a little silly things repeat back
to what you say with Simon Says you know
that's a lot of it right any new and a
new paradigms gonna have that kind of
novelty to it but we're starting to see
real usage actually people are actually
ordering lifts people are ordering food
they're sending tweets and it's becoming
an actual thing and not going the way of
a 3d TV right so why are we seeing the
actual usage you can ask well I mean I
think I can speak for people here at
this conference and that we all want
Jarvis and that's the dream right but
but beyond that for you know nan Jarvis
see people conversational applications
are easy to get started with right
they're a little more friendly than then
what we have out there now and they're
fun people enjoy playing around with
them trying things to see if it'll
respond to them you know it's just it's
just it's just yeah novelty begets usage
right Alexa turn on the living room
lights saying it's a lot easier than
getting out your phone and finding the
app and I don't anything up if you
already have the hue app tapping on
living room and you know we live in the
future no one hits witches anymore so
the faster way to get the lights on the
better all right this is a very easy
easy way and grandmothers can do this
kind of thing right
speaking of them there are still a lot
of people that are genuinely confused by
their desktop and even their tablets and
this is just one more step if you do the
app correctly that they can make it and
get actions done and compute on a
platform without having to know doc
versus Start menu or you know where iOS
keeps the app tray and all that kind of
stuff not surprisingly of course young
people have jumped on the conversational
bandwagon more quickly than most and you
see app usage in and in younger apps you
know can tell it or your people getting
more a lot of usage no further example
than my four-year-old daughter
who
really used Alexa as her very first
computing platform we had to coach her
to speak a little more slowly Alexa had
to learn the speech patterns of a time
three year old but they came together
pretty quickly and now she does all
kinds of things right she's she's
telling Alexa to crank it up when a song
she's playing she likes is on she asked
to tell a joke all the time she doesn't
get any of the jokes but she laughs
anyway she's a great audience and the
other day I walked in to the living room
and she told Alexa I love you which you
know lobar she's four she loves
everybody but but still though having
that emotional connection with an app
you kind of talked to and interface more
than just clicking or tapping is you
know not crazy right you feel a
connection to these apps if they were
built correctly that you wouldn't have
normally with a Photoshop you know no
one's ever told Photoshop it was their
best friend or confessed our love group
four Clippy right
maybe Photoshop definitely not Clippy no
one loves Clippy I'd even make that that
was out there already which I thought
was great right like you know in the
excitement for these apps is is also
true for developers we're seeing a spike
in skills as Alexa calls them on their
skill store that are coming in all the
time here's a random screen shot I took
of this and there's just all kinds of
crazy apps coming on all the time
they're really getting very excited
about it and you know there are
obviously apps that works beautifully on
these kind of platforms I'm sure all of
you know about them right things like 20
questions right easy right it works
great on Alexa and you can play as a
group automatic has an app so kind of
car automation you can ask you know
Alexa how much gas do I have before you
leave the house or how you know how long
have I driven the other day
uber super simple right I need an uber
you know you call the you call an uber
with Alexa it sits there about you while
you're still getting kind of ready for
the day there are other apps that just
have to exist because it's the internet
so you know for example cat fax you know
we're all looking for a way to get cat
fax more easily and this is the is the
bleeding edge we're also always looking
for a faster way to make a fart joke and
that exists as well
you know I get it makes perfect sense
yes for a fart farts the next one is a
little harder to understand but you know
God exists that someone made it it's a
pickup lines one I don't get it
I don't know if I see a lot of people
plugging in echos and bars but you know
if for some reason this crazy echo de
Bergerac scheme works for you then you
can continue the the ruse with a
marriage app no idea what this thing
gives you I couldn't get it to work
actually turns on but you know great
okay now if you need that's way to get
help then by all means the next one
actually that I found of an example is
as is like my favorite Richard Stallman
fun facts how many can there be right
and it wouldn't even like this it's on
Amazon but besides the point
the one thing that you'll notice right
away on the store as well is is there is
a quote bot for every famous person who
has ever said anything ever specifically
old white guys who look great in black
and white pictures but seriously there's
a lot of quote apps and you know good
job
glad you made them but I think it really
speaks to the fact that developers were
excited about these platforms and they
want to make something with it and then
they look at the empty sublime text
window ended up making a quote app right
because it's just hard to it's a very
different thing to make these apps so a
valid question is what do you make and
these at what works well for
conversational applications music right
is a great use case you know things that
are very single tasks right you want to
be very specific tasks that you you know
things that you want to play this song
song plays right hands-free cooking you
know I look at things like that like
chain you know metrics or repeating a
recipe back because you're doing
something you don't want to do that
thing where you swipe the phone without
trying to get the look on your hands on
it you know avoiding that is a great use
for these and then you know automation
right you don't want emissions all over
the place and and one thing that works
really well that is kind of I think a
lot of people are its obviously you
think about it but a little bit of
surprise is family or group use
specifically an echo or eventually
Google home these things they're gonna
sit on a shelf they're not someone's in
their pocket right where you have to you
know ask for their code
to get in families and groups can use
these apps really easily ordering things
on Amazon or playing a game together and
that kind of stuff really plays well on
this and yes if you need to get an
Einstein quote to get to your day those
are fantastic uses for this as well so
again single tasks keeping it simple
what are the pro tips then right if you
have an app idea now that works what are
the ways to make it really sing one is
very your responses and I think this is
the easiest to do and the biggest gain
which is basically just don't say ok
every time when the user asked the drama
lights those slight variations which
everyone immediately knows how to do
right and array I pick a random one have
an array of affirmative responses
something as simple as that
make sure app feels so much more alive
that you're doing different responses
you get back I have a little personality
or application to surprise rather than
let them down we can't make Jarvis
Jarvis doesn't exist so don't make an
app that promises the world and then
responds with I don't know what you're
talking about for nine times out of ten
when your requests be very specific
about what the app is supposed to do but
if there's a great little way to add
something you know ask to share
something after they've made it or just
a little little things that come up in
the application development that oh it'd
be great if I could do this that's a
great way to make it feel more alive
without having to ask for the world and
not knowing how to answer any of those
questions evolve your app so you're
seeing a theme simple simple simple is
the theme here but you know a key
element that the developers forget about
this too is that you have to really drag
your users along right yet to start with
a very specific use case release let him
use it then do another release to add a
feature and kind of go at a very
methodical pace there's no update screen
now it's not even a menu that they can
see the new stuff on so you have to kind
of really pull them through to let them
know of a new feature and and it's it's
really important that you evolve and
start slow and evolve it also instantly
helps you because you need to as well
see map out these models these speech
models and that way you're going to grow
slowly with them as well the good news
is
on this is that the turnaround time on
these apps was pretty quick because you
don't have to worry about UI so you can
develop a whole version of this fairly
quickly a lot more quick than you could
do an iPhone app or you're worrying
about you know the great way they have
the visual UI clearly clearly cue the
user you know when you need input tell
them you need input don't just kind of
stop talking you gotta let them know
that they need to talk and if they if
they if it's a question that they need
to think about like it's a game a trivia
game don't just you know give up on them
you got to make sure that you keep the
session open and let them respond and
cue them again it's very important that
just people don't see this stuff so they
gotta got to be a helpful on to the
process minimize options same thing you
know keep don't ask him for four or five
things at a time ask him for one thing
at a time and keep it things very
specific so that they can get through it
without being able to see anything
lastly let people be polite there's a
lot of apps where people want to say
please and thank you in these apps right
they do they want to be polite not on
the highway not at the Trump rally but
most other places they do want to be
polite and and you need to let them be
polite don't let a please or a thank you
throw off your speech model right so
that's the contest's that kind of the
pro tips and and the best way to make an
app the best ideas for apps let's
quickly go through about how to actually
make an app this is gonna be very
specific to Alexa obviously the apps are
arrest interfaces but they're you know
obviously very tiered towards towards
Amazon's particular needs so here's a
general flow right this is from Amazon
the little man talks to the aleko device
and the service then parses out what
skill they're called after called skills
you're talking about and then pulls out
the variables that that skill is defined
to look for sends that over to your app
number four which then does whatever
turns on a light in this case and then
what's not shown here is you respond
back with either a verbal response or
optionally a an image or text you can
send of the app for Amazon's case so
we're gonna get to code encodes
obviously important we're at a coding
conference but
in these kind of apps when your your map
out of speech model you can't sleep on
the configuration stuff this is this is
really most of the app and you do it all
today in this case the Amazon dashboard
but Facebook or the other ones have the
same kind of thing and there are two key
parts of this one is the intent and the
other part is the utterances and these
are the ways you're kind of teaching the
model to learn how to work with your app
so this is the example of an intent so
the intent is a JSON file we've got a
manual 8 a JSON it's fun for you and
what you're doing is you're just listing
out all the different types of requests
your app will get this example the
Jeopardy obviously a start Jeopardy
intent has no variables you just you
know can i play a game you know kind of
thing versus the pick category intent
has one variable a category so you have
to go through you're not worried about
verbage here you're just worried about
the types of tests that you want to call
them coming in and the variables that
they should pull out for you so as your
request will have the intent name and
then the variables they pulled
utterances are the example text and this
is where you're really changing the
system turn Trank training the system
sorry you can see you have the intent
name and then an example phrase so start
jeopardy ask jeopardy to start a game
that's what that's saying there or play
a game so you get to do all the
different variations the more the
merrier on this kind of thing when you
have one that's a variable you can see
they pull out food cat or you say you
know give me a food question so food is
example and you're saying this food word
is an example of the category variable
and and as you do more and more and more
and more and more and again the more the
merrier they will learn to pick out
those variables when they send it to
your app so this you're gonna come back
to this a thousand times when you're
making your app because our gonna think
of a new way to say something or a
variable is gonna slip through and
you'll be going back and forth it
editing this so this is going to be an
integral part of the thing so assuming
we've got that good again you're gonna
go back to that a lot but the actual app
itself now let's run through that like I
said rest application fairly
straightforward JSON passing back and
forth right it's got a bunch of security
requests
we'll get to in a second and the three
request types are launched intent and
session ended which are fairly
self-explanatory to go back to the
application flow real quickly now the
fort you know so that we configured
number two and now we're gonna go on to
number four and like I said there's a
lot of security stuff which is great
right Amazon does a very good job of
making sure that these requests are
coming to to them and them alone and are
going under your request to you or
coming from them and if you know it's
good stuff and here's a list it's you
know verifying the request from them and
doing checking their signature and the
timestamp it's got it's so much stuff
it's a lot and you don't want to do this
every time so they know this and what
they suggest that you do is use their
lambda service if you're not familiar
lamda came out I guess two years ago I
guess it allows you to upload code
primarily JavaScript but I think there's
a lot of languages now and runs on their
service per request and they've built in
a ton of libraries that allow you to not
have to worry about this or this right
and they you know doing the check either
responses its SSL for you automatically
free and it's you know it's great it
allows you to really play with the
system really easily however I didn't
want to use lambda I wanted to use
something that ran on my server at home
so I could have it interact with some of
the stuff in my house right the kind of
the whole reason the Jarvis stuff right
I also did want to run it in JavaScript
no offense I wanted to write it and go
which I was playing with a lot lately
so so I built a library originally named
called go Alexa that allows you to not
have to worry about all the security
stuff it takes all the Borla printout
and allows you to just focus on making
your app because again you want these to
be simple you're gonna make a bunch
right so there's go Alexa don't steal
the name it's super original and this is
it so this right here is a fully
functional go Alexa app right 21 lines
whatever so you're not worried about any
of the stuff they have you go through
use and will just go through this you I
got a better slides here
first is application definition and if
you don't know go I think goes pretty
readable and I'll kind of step through
it and there's not a lot of code in this
but but it is go this is just you know a
slice or an array of your applications
you can run multiple application of the
same binary in this case so you're
defining an endpoint you're defining the
app ID that you get from Amazon and then
you're putting handler functions for
each of the major in you know intense or
on launch handle events that come
through for those that do no go might be
wondering why I'm using an interface up
there and that is because you can also
pass in Alexa dot standard application
types if you wanted to run like a
regular website out of the same binary
to a login page or a you know the
website for your app or something like
that okay handler so a handler takes in
an echo request type and an echo
response type you look at the
information on the request and you
modify the response it's pretty simple
example admittedly let's look a little
slightly more example a better example
here so I think it's fairly readable
this one you can see is doing a switch
statement on on the type of intent that
comes in and you know if it's a status
1/10 in this case this is something I
wrote that pings are companies that is
page and just tells me if everything is
fine or not so it's parsing through some
JSON says yep everything is fine and
then outputs the message all
applications are good or it outputs
something is down and then if something
you know the 10th company we didn't know
about it'll say I'm sorry and keep the
session open so you can ask again so
still a simple example admittedly but
you can see that you're not worrying
about any Alexis specific stuff you're
just worried about your app and you know
you could easily modify this to use a
different kind of you know the Google
home comes out and do something easily
you could easily do this the same kind
of thing because you're not worrying
about a lot of Alexis specific stuff
lastly is the main function which could
not be simple and I don't want you to
slide for it you just Alexa run pass it
the applications slice and a port and
that's it and then it you know it just
runs as a regular go by to have you want
to run
so it gets at handles the incoming JSON
body handles the outgoing JSON response
to handles all the requests you just
need to worry about SSL and running the
app somewhere so another you're gonna do
a lot of in addition to you know the app
is gonna be fairly simple more than
likely you're gonna be playing with the
speech model a lot and you're also gonna
be testing it a lot so how do you test
these apps is a very good question if
you have an Alexa device already like an
echo or fire stick or I think it's the
main ones right now as long as you're
logged in with your same developer
account on that device you can leave
your apps in development mode and they
will automatically be available on that
device and to be quite frank everything
I've written is still in developer mode
because if not a lot of you know most of
it is kind of personal stuff that I've
written for home automation and even
bigger stuff there's no way to monetize
that or even cover the cost of the
hosting so I've been leaving everything
in develop mode and no one seemed to
care if you do not have an Alexa device
or you want to test on a different one
for whatever reason
Alexa Amazon has put out a web version
of echo at Ecco symbiote and there was
also some really great apps that come
out that also plug into the Alexa voice
interface that can use every skill just
like anything else can the one that I
use is an Android app called LexA it's a
Play Store link for it but you hit a
button you talk and it's Lux it made it
works really well so covered a lot of
ground but a couple of takeaway points
for all of this stuff one keep things
simple I cannot stress that one enough
you want to have things as simple as
possible so that your app and your
speech model is as clean and simple as
possible because you gonna be going back
and forth even something a simple task
you're gonna be going back and tweaking
a different way to say something or
you'll you know your I guarantee you the
first person you show it to will say it
no way you never freaking thought they
would say and the thing will say I don't
you're talking about no I apologize I
mean they'll work on that I guarantee
you it's gonna happen so keeping things
simple allow you to not have to get in
the weeds with 7,000 things you need to
recognize and just really focus on
turning the lights on or
ordering something or booking a flight
whatever it may be and again it also
keeps things simple for the user so that
they're not having to stab around with
random requests and things they're just
able to say what they need and get out
to keep that keep that interface simple
to use a library I'm not one of those
guys always have to use libraries for
everything but in this case I would
highly recommend it because if you keep
things simple you will need to make a
lot of little apps and you do not want
to implement the checking of timestamps
and the verifying of the certificate and
the signature and a lot kind of stuff
every time so you know if you want to
write it and go I think my library's
pretty good if you want to write it in
something else there's a library for
most I think most every language has a
has a has a library now and if you don't
wanna worry about anything
then I suggest to use lambda but but use
something because it's so new you're
gonna want to you know like I said play
with that speech model play with the way
your kind of app interacts with the user
and has a conversation back and forth
you're not gonna want to worry about all
the different security stuff which is
good but you just not gonna want to
implement it every time and lastly and I
think this is really the most important
one don't make a quote app we're good
we're really good unquote apps if you
have to make a code app make it about
someone who's not old and white I guess
but outside of that just we're good
we're good
so that's pretty much it
I've got the my code up on github in
that go Alexa library there is the full
jeopardy app is there don't release it
you remember the Alex Trebek eyebrows
but it's all in there including the
intense and the utterances so you can
fully configure the app to see how it
all works even with the configuration
stuff it's also a few hello world stuff
in there and I'd love to see what you
make if you make an app whether it's
echo or Facebook Messenger or whatever
it may be
as long as it's not quote based I would
love to see it so it's send it over to
our Twitter's on there my website and
it's it'd be great to get some explosion
of you know really great developers
making on these apps because it's it's
it's super fun and it just needs to have
a little more not quote stuff you know
so
thank you that's it
so we got time for questions anyone has
questions start a front so you're
dependent on the platforms and right now
no not with Alexis stuff which is why
everything's in dev mode for me on the
tech side messenger Facebook Messenger
has some some ways you can buy things
through apps you can't buy the bot
itself but you can buy things in the bot
and the one caveat for Facebook Lassiter
is you there isn't a built-in speech
model with it you'd have to implement
your own icon a wit AI or something like
that they just have the general bot back
and forth interface so if you want to do
the conversational stuff you need to go
and find your own but but you can sell
things in facebook messenger but not the
other ones not yet
only done is interesting the most of the
stuff that I really got excited about
first is is stuff there's just faster
you know things that you could because
you didn't want to have to do and pull
out a phone and do the whole thing
ordering an uber while you're getting
ready in the morning checking the
traffic that kind of stuff is is really
good I think there are some things that
were kind of developing and kicking
around that are almost so much better
there there really makes sense on these
and that's kind of the group games make
a lot of sense you know that's that kind
of family style develop applications are
things that you don't really see on
phones and tablets because they're all
kind of hardwired to at least somebody
so that stuff is something I'd really
like to see more of and I think it
regulars who are on the platform yeah
right timers are a lot yeah everybody's
the timers first for sure so right now
with Alexa as it stands and from what I
understand they're adding new versions
of this but the way you trigger a skill
they call it is you have to say Alexa
tell jeopardy or Alessa ask Jeopardy yep
there's a variations in there but right
now it's kind of something of some kind
of verb and then an intent name they
don't have that pattern just kind of the
way it is right now I think Google home
might be experimenting with new ways to
do it but I haven't talked about it yet
and I know that Alexa is also trying to
expand that but right now it's a little
more rigid in the way you call the apps
yes it's a good point yeah you got to
really play around with that they've
added a lot more I didn't cover it in
this but they've added a lot more of the
variable types and intents so you can
say early on they just kind of had
string or an array of things you can
tell them it's an option
they've added a lot more and they're
getting better with numbers but it's
still it's still kind of a longer
testing cycle when you use numbers
you've got to make sure you're you're
checking on your side to make sure it
could be a string there might not be
string that kind of stuff yes I think I
have I think it has launched it
somewhere else maybe um I don't know if
it's officially launched in you know
completely dependent on their luck so
service so it could turn on tomorrow
they could announce that it's in Russian
and everything would be fine
but I don't know exactly what other
countries is in I thought it was in a
few but I couldn't tell you exactly what
other countries they've launched in
so as it stands right now is a great
question might if this is my most
requested feature right now no however I
just got a servant in a day from Amazon
Alexa asking me how I would like to have
that work so they are clearly well aware
of this and I and I think the Google
home if you watch the demo video of that
they show a notification pinging the
person and I'm sure that put pressure on
them
shameless why there's a $50 echo dot
that screwed me over from when I've had
a hundred ollars for one but but yeah
they're there I think they're coming to
terms on that pretty quickly way back
there so if you don't have an intent for
like if they say you didn't put an
intent for some action and there's no
utterances for it and they say ask
jeopardy to you know make me a pie you I
believe it depends on how bad they
mangle up right if they if they
completely screw it up it'll say I don't
know what you're talking about you won't
get a request at all
I think otherwise it might default to a
session start command maybe just to say
hey this person talked to you but I
don't know what the heck they said and
it'll tell the Motorsports back to say I
don't I don't know what you know this
this skill doesn't respond to this
intent or so you don't say some kind of
error message to them yes yes it is
right now there's not a great logging of
seeing how people missed it right now
that I'm aware of if it's in dev mode
yes yes if it's in dev mode so yeah
you're right that's a good point if
you're in dev mode you can actually see
and you can do it yourself too as you're
talking if you miss it you can look and
see how it interpreted your skill your
text once it's in prod I don't think
there's anything they don't get anything
back to you I don't think but in Mill
there yeah
yeah as far as I know and there you know
or kind of Michigan time there they do
the same kind of thing that Google does
which is they will store it but they say
it's anonymized data and they will store
it to make their system better you know
that kind of keep it around for a
certain amount of time but I don't know
they've ever released and said it's a
hard this many weeks or this many months
then we clear it out I don't know I
don't think I've ever said that publicly
but I do know they keep it around to
rerun them on you know I imagine they
imagine they check the requests after
you they hear you say a curse word or
two right kind of stuff
right yeah it's good question so as you
know and that's kind of plays into
keeping things targeted you know a new
feature that's completely yeah it's
always add assignment just new is the
new feature should be a second skill or
it should be in the other app if it's if
it's something that's kind of a next
step of this of the step you already
took right if it's like I said if it's
you're booking a flight with it and then
when they booked the flight successfully
it you say hey would you like to be an
email this to four or five people you
know right off so any modules that kind
of stuff works really well and you gotta
you just gotta let them know you just
gotta verbalize the new feature of you
know yeah can I help you with this other
ways you can do it is if you get back a
wonky you could put in your code if you
get back kind of a wonky response you
could kick into something to say we
maybe you could try this or there's a
new feature there it's it's an art you
got to kind of work it in there and
that's why you got to go slow is because
depending on the feature there's
probably four or five different ways you
could try to kind of work it in and
maybe the answer is this should just be
a separate skill that day that's always
got to be in the back your mind too so
you get in the initial request you will
get a Amazon user ID and an Amazon
session ID the session is for that
session obviously and once they stop
using the app the session dies shortly
after that I think unless they kick it
right back on they give you a little bit
of window in case they accidentally
closed it early and they get back in
that session I think stays alive a
little bit longer you get an Amazon user
ID that is unique to that user and I and
is in the stay unless they're on a whole
different device the ID is still good
for that user so you can kind of come
back and go hi whatever you are this is
you know I saw you before you can kind
of know that but if they go to an echo
and they go to their phone they'll get a
new user ID in that case there is also a
workflow they recently launched where
you can kick them into a workflow to
have them sign up with your app and then
you can link accounts it's still newish
most apps don't use it the ones that are
built into like an uber and that kind of
stuff do obviously because you got to
pay for it but there is a workflow for
that if you want to actually link it
permanently
with a user on your side I've never hit
it I don't know if there's a hard limit
on how much how long it is I know
there's there are certainly no taps out
there there's an email app I've seen
that that you probably go pretty long
there is a timeout to waiting it's a few
seconds I don't know 10 or sup like that
seconds if you haven't said anything and
it'll send a request that you can then
reap romp them if you want but I don't
think that mean there must be but I've
never hit it they give you a plenty of
time to actually start keep talking if
you want to keep talking no not yet
that'd be cool though I'm good on time
we're all done
Oh any other questions there you go
yeah so I don't I can't remember the
exact list of what it's been released of
I know it's it does a pretty good job
you've got to train it but it does a
pretty good job with accents but it's
still English accents right it's still
you have to have the act but I think
they either have or they're shortly but
really seek another country but I don't
know the list of top of my head but I
know it does pretty well actually with
accents
I know I know they have to yeah there's
a way in the app to say trigger training
have you read a few things back and
forth and it like I said it got my
three-year-old kid kind of accent so
that's that's a pretty rough one
sometimes and then she got they got that
eventually it said all right thank you